그럼 왓드스는 어때요?
세밀하게 조율이 안 되네요.
아 어떡하라고 다 만들어졌는데
언제부터 바꾸냐.
쿠팡의 고가 금액을 사실 때는
조금 신중하셔야 돼요.
메가 인플루언서 셀러분들
어느 정도 벌고 있는지 저희가 알 수 있을까요?
엄청 예민한 질문.
결과적으로 공동구매 시장에서
가장 돈이 되는 분야는 지금 어떤 걸까요?
소비문화 이면에 경제 이야기
비주류 경제학 코스트를 맡은
저는 장석종, 유식맨이고요.
저는 재무덕 구이재용입니다.
이번 주 비주류 경제학 주제는
인플루언서인데요.
게스트로 뽀큐2 유봉석 대표님 모셨습니다.
반갑습니다.
개인적으로 너무나 팬이어서
이렇게 팬이라고 하면 안 믿으실 수도 있지만
대부분의 방송을 다 봤습니다.
감사합니다.
진짜요?
뭔가 살 때
살 때는 항상 뒤에 뽀큐2님 붙여서 검색을 한번 해본다.
그래서 어떻게 말씀을 하셨나 체크를 하고
그래서 최근에도 빗셀 샀고
버미큘라도 사고
뭐 이것저것 좀 많이 샀습니다.
굉장히 하이엔드만 골랐어 딱 딱.
취향이
모르시세요.
어떻게 생각하셨어요?
뽀큐2님 혹시 알고 계셨나요?
저도 당연히 뭐 시작하실 때부터 알고 있었고요.
많은 분들이 알고 계신지 제가 홈쇼핑 출신인데
제가 회사 생활과 유튜브 생활을 3년 3개월 병행을 했었거든요.
혹시 뭐 홈쇼핑 사람들 유튜브 하는 사람 없나 하면서
누가 등장할 때마다 막 체크해봐서
되게 초반부터 알고 있었어요.
처음 시작하실 때부터
사실 유튜버라고 하기 되게 애매해요.
왜요?
사실상은 물건을 판매하는 그냥 경로 정도로 이용하고 있지
따지고 보면 브랜드사 개발사 그냥 유통까지 같이 하고 있는
근데 근데 어쩌다 보니까 대표이사가 유튜브에서 조금 노출을 시킨다
이 정도의 맥락으로 이해해 주시면 빠를 것 같아요.
대표님은 브랜드 개발 유통 이게 메인이지
네 맞아요.
어떻게 보면은 유튜브는 필요해서 하는 약간
조금 얻어 걸렸어요.
얻어 걸린?
진짜 쌩뚱맞게 얻어 걸렸어요.
나중에 말씀드리겠지만
이거는 실력인데 얻어 걸린 게 아니라
그러니까 아니 보통은 유튜브를 하다가 유명해져서 내가 그걸로
해야겠다 이런 식으로 하는 분이 많잖아요.
그렇게 잘 안 되고요.
사실 제가 실제로 공동구매 하겠어라고 공부를 한 건 21년도에요.
얼마 안 되네요.
네 21년도에요.
근데 그 이전에 몇 년 동안도 충분히 이렇게 인플루언서나 공구시장
소위 말하는 파리피플이라고 조롱 당하던 사람들의 시장이 무지막지하게 컸는데
저는 이제 메인스트림인 홈쇼핑에서 매출을 일으키고 있는 회사였기 때문에
그들을 폄훼하거나 무시했었어요.
아 얘기 재밌는데 거리의식이다 이거 특권의식 나는 홈쇼핑에서 팔고 있는데
저 밑에 파리피플들은 좀 별 좀 이렇게 급이 났다.
약간 효소파네 주변에다가 뭐라 그랬냐면 제가 홈쇼핑하는 사람들하고 같이 모이잖아요.
그럼 유통회사들이랑 이렇게 모이면 다 같은 얘기할 때 제가 주도적으로 나서 가지고
이런 건전하지 못한 유통은 박멸해야 된다 박멸 에프킬라 뿌리자 거기를 지금
들어왔어요 5년 전에 2021년에 기꺼이 힘기기가 되신
사실 코로나가 아니었으면 홈쇼핑 에서는 꽤 많은 유통사가 많이 무너졌을 거예요.
코로나 때 다 집에 앉아서 TV만 보니까 잠깐 올라온 거거든요.
근데 저는 그때 회사가 망했어요. 제조를 건드리는 바람에
그러니까 아주 대다수의 부품이 들어와야 되는 중국이 그냥 셧다운 돼버리니까
정말 고시원에 이렇게 매트 올리고 있는 그 전후 일주일 사이로 알고리즘이 터지는 거예요.
유튜브가
그때 컨텐츠가 올라온 게 물건 살 돈이 없어가지고 그냥 말로 떼 오는 걸 했어요.
내가 알고 있는 모든 지식을 업계의 비기를 터트리고 나는 장렬히 불태우고
끝내겠다 해서 이 시장 전체 블렌더 시장에 대한 얘기 프라이팬에 대한 얘기
막 이런 식으로 한 열몇 개를 했고 그게 다 떠버린 거예요.
그 고시원에 있는 상태에서 이제 소통을 하지 않습니까.
댓글도 보고 분위기 하는데 너가 상품을 좀 그냥 팔지 뭐 그렇게 추천만 해 해서 제가 원래
이제
다수의 제조사들과 유통사들과 브랜드사들하고 거래를 했으니까
개중에 한 브랜드를 제가 딱 콕 집어서 영상에 탁 노출했어요.
근데 그게 120만 뷰가 뜬 거예요.
어떤 제품이었을까요.
알텐바흐 아 알텐바흐 프라이팬 탁 뜬 거예요.
그쪽 사장님이 공구 한번 해볼래 그래서 이제 그 공구 제안을 커뮤니티에 올려가지고 슬쩍 물어봤는데
뭔 소리야 무조건 해야지 이런 분위기에요.
구독자분들이.
네.
지금은 오히려 거꾸로 팔 거 아니면 올리지도 마.
와 나 진짜 와 잘해.
파라조 피플이.
그러니까 파라조 피플이 어디서 떨어진 거야 갑자기.
그러니까 이런 특이 케이스로 나올 때도 처음에 쫄딱 망해 있던 상태였고 뒤돌아갈 곳이 없는 상태였기 때문에.
근데 구독자분들이 포큐티님이 망했는지 안 했는지 자세히는 모를 거잖아요.
알고 있었죠.
알고 있었어요.
끝 무렵에 라이브를 한번 켰는데 그때 이제 막 엉엉 울면서 한 얘기를 하죠.
실은 내가 망했어.
육식민 님이 보시기엔 같은 유튜버로서 이 성공은 어떻게 보십니까?
정말 이례적인 일이에요.
사실 유튜브는 저희 아마 많은 분들 기억하실 텐데 뒷광고 논란 있었어요.
그래서 그때 막 어떤 유튜버들 막 접기도 하시고 했던 그런 큰일이 나고 나서 유튜버가 뭔가 수익 활동으로 하는 것을 부도덕시하는 문화까지도 갔었던 게 한국 유튜브 문화였어요.
근데 포큐티 님의 성공을 모두가 다 잘 알고 있었고 유튜브를 주시해 보는 사람들은 너무 놀랍게 생각을 했었어요.
그러니까 홈쇼핑 채널을 사실상 유튜브에 이식하는 데 성공한 일이고 일종의 자기 유튜브 채널을 플랫폼화하는 데 성공시킨 굉장히 이례적인 사례였어요.
최초의 인물인 줄 알았어요.
정확히 말하면 커머스는 할 수 있어요.
이른바 수수료 형식의 광고는 할 수 있죠.
광고 영상을 해서 개수에 따라서 연동되는 수익을 받을 수 있는데 공구라는 단어.
그렇죠. 그렇죠.
그런 단어를 쓰는 거는 거의 이제 유튜브한테는 그냥 나락스텝이에요. 나락스텝.
그럼 만약에 약간 플랫폼 자체가 인스타그램으로 바뀌었다면 좀 얘기가 달라졌을 수도 있어요.
완전 다르죠.
아, 그래요?
우리는 뭐 공동체죠. 그냥 우리는.
저는 수많은 유튜버들과 그래머들과 틱톡커들도 만나봤으니까 완전 달라요.
인스타는요. 이건 제 그냥 개인적인 생각이긴 한데 기본적으로 굉장히 탄미적인 성격이 크다고 생각해요.
탄미적인.
예뻐야 된다. 아름다워야 된다.
크기 때문에 예쁜 걸 보려고 들어가는 거예요. 인스타는.
릴스인데 아주 예쁜 분이 머리만 넘기는데 그거 그냥 3초 계속 돌아가는데 좋아요 100만 개 눌려져 있고 이런 거 있잖아요.
그냥 예쁘면 좋아하는 거예요. 인스타는.
유튜브는 다르거든요. 유튜브는 기본적으로 재미를 얻으려고 하고 정보를 얻으려고 보는 TV를 대체한 미디어 중 하나이기 때문에 사람들이 클릭했을 때 한 8분 이상 나오길 바라잖아요.
그런데 생각보다 8분 이상 떠들었을 때 재미있는 사람이 정말 많아요.
그거는 정말 능력이 있어야 되는 일이거든요.
그런 의미에서 셀링을 한다고 했을 때 대부분 사람들이 인스타부터 시작하고 유튜브로 셀링을 하겠다고 꿈을 꾸는 사람은 턱없이 적죠.
그러니까 흔히 말하는 파리피플 그런 분들이 대부분 인스타에 계신 이유도 거기에도 있죠.
진집이 훨씬 쉽다. 유튜브가 어렵기도 한데 팔기도 어렵고 되게 힘든 길이네요.
그렇죠.
힘든 거 하고 계시네요.
너무 힘든 걸 하셔서 크게 버신 거예요.
알고리즘 우리는 솔직히 태운다고 그러는데 유튜브에서는 정말 하늘의 별따기잖아요. 최소 1년은 정보해줘야 될까 말까 하거든요.
한 만 명 갈까 말까인데 인스타그램은 조금 플레이 잘하고 감각 있으신 트렌드를 조금만 읽는 사람들이 들어와도 한 6개월이면 몇 만 명 만듭니다.
5만 명까지도 금방 만들어요.
그럼 혹시 제품 카테고리 별로 인스타에서 잘 되는 게 있고 유튜브에서 잘 되는 게 있고 이런 게 혹시 있나요?
이게 너무 명확하죠.
정말요?
또렷하죠. 일단 인스타 쪽에서는 가전은 생각보다 안 돼요.
그래요? 나는 인스타에서도 팔로우하고 있는 분이 있는데.
그게 전체 볼륨으로 보는 거죠. 저는 여기 있는 게 셀러가 아니라 물건을 공급하는 공급자 입장에서 보는 거죠.
예를 들면 우리 잇섭 님 같은 분들. 옛날에는 완전 테크만 하다가 요즘은 한 번씩 음수익물 처리기도 파시고 리빙 카테고리의 가전들도 유튜브 리뷰가 쏟아지지 나오고
그쪽 커머스가 되게 더 활성화돼 있어요.
사실 수익 구조는 인스타그램으로 가는 게 판매자 입장에서는 더 편하거든요.
유튜브로 갔을 때는 질문의 수위가 치밀함과 정교함이 댓글이 막 그건 왓드스는 어때요? 세밀하게 조율이 안 되네요.
어떡하라고 다 만들어줬는데 언제까지 다르냐.
단점이 없는 제품은 없잖아요.
계속 달리는데 딴 거 사. 마음이 여기까지 올라오는데.
올라오지만?
인스타에서는 뭘 팔아야 돼요?
예를 들면 뷰티는 유튜브에서 잘 안 팔려요.
그렇네. 못 본 거 같아.
잘 안 팔려요.
단점이 드러나는구나.
안 보이려고 해도 스치듯이 보이고요. 뭔가 별거 아닌 영상에서 오해도 받고.
인스타그램에서는 길어봤자 1분 30초니까.
뷰티도 사실 100만 원짜리 디바이스를 파는데 유튜브에서는 20분짜리를 찍어야 살까 말까 할걸요.
근데 인스타에서는 리얼스 한 두세 개면 삽니다.
100만 원짜리요?
네.
바로 삽니다.
뷰티는 완전히 릴스랑 틱톡으로 마케팅 수단이 넘어갔어요.
패션은 어떻게 팔아야 돼요?
너무 어려워요.
너무 궁금해요.
패션 어떻게 팔아야 돼요?
저는 물어보고 다니고 있어요. 요즘 옷을 어떻게 보고 사세요? 너무 파편화돼 있어서.
석종님도 한번 의견이 있으실 것 같은데 패션은 어떻게 해야 돼요?
저는 인플루언서 시딩도 많이 해보고 실제로 공동구매까지는 아니지만 주변의 사례들도 있고.
근데 패션은 거부감이 정말 커요.
그리고 저렇게 이쁜 애가 입으니까 쩌 느낌이지.
특히 남성 패션 시장은 저는 제로라고 봅니다.
그럼 패션 인플루언서는 어떻게 살아야 돼요?
이게 인플루언서들이 어떤 식으로 활용이 되냐면 정말 그 사람을 보고 바로 바로 사는 게 아니라 사례들이 굉장히 많이 모여있고 인스타그램 태그 같은 게 걸려있잖아요.
그러면 내가 이 물건을 사기 위해서 그 태그 들어가서 보고 이런 느낌이 들어요.
그 태그가 이구나 참고하는 정도랄까?
그냥 룩북으로서의 가치네요.
룩북이죠.
인간 룩북으로서의 가치.
실제 패션에서는 메가셀러들이 존재했었어요.
그렇죠.
서방...
초기에는 다 메가셀러가 패션 앤 뷰티였어요.
그들의 브랜드로 실제로 성공한 브랜드들이 지금도 몇 개 존재해요.
예를 들면 한스스타일도 있고,
깔랑도 있고 이런 분들이 있어요.
깔랑이 우리나라 1세대에서는 제일 큰 셀러인데 그녀의 브랜드는 루피움이라고.
그게 뷰티 쪽으로 훨씬 큰데.
근데 그게 인플루언서 브랜드인지 아무도 몰라요.
매자릿수 매출을 일으킵니다.
연간.
이런 브랜드들이 있지만 요즘 안 되는 이유는 원체 정교해지기도 했고요.
종류가 너무 많고 그다음에 개수도 많고 컬러 사이즈 이 이슈들 때문에 쉬운 쪽으로 가요.
새로 인입되는 인플루언서들은 요즘 스타트업하고 똑같아요.
불과 한 5, 6년 전만 해도 스타트업들이 리빙도 있었고 되게 장르가 많았거든요.
지금 스타트업은 전부 뷰티만 합니다.
뷰티가 최고지.
APR 바라보고 전부 그것만 봅니다.
재용님 혹시 이런 공동구매 좀 해보신 적 있으세요?
저는 없죠.
저는 사실 냉정합니다.
냉정한 소비자.
개별 구매만 하시는.
절대 추천해주는 거 사지 않는다.
딱 한 번 있는데 안 그래도 휴가 가려고 했는데 저기 리조트 할인해준다.
이런 거 한 번 사본 적 있어요.
진짜 필요한 거.
진짜 필요한 거죠.
안 그래도 가려고 했는데 싸게 파네.
아니 거의 쇼핑 자체를 썩 즐기지 않으시는 것 같은데요?
그것도 맞아요.
이런 분들은 사실 표본에서 제외해야 됩니다.
그렇지.
나가라고 할까요?
이 재무증인 입장에서 봤을 때 이 공동구매 핵심은 뭐라고 생각하시나요?
기본적으로 제조사 입장에서는 공동구매를 하는 이유는 기본적으로 짧은 기간에 많은 매출을 낼 수 있다.
그래서 마진을 어느 정도 이제 쉐어해야 되기 때문에 마진을 희생하는 거긴 하지만
그렇게 해서 인플루언서의 영향으로 짧은 기간에 큰 매출을 만들 수 있다면
보통 신제품을 런칭하기에 딱 좋은 아이예요.
런칭하기에 딱 좋은 아이템들을 공동구매로 보내는 게 제일 좋은 것 같고요.
그다음에 인플루언서 입장에서는 자기가 이제 우리 구독자 내지는 팔로워랑 쌓았던 신뢰를
라포 이런 것들을 레버리지 삼아서 판매할 수 있는 어떻게 보면 좋은 수익화 채널이기도 하고
고객 입장에서도 내가 좋아하는 포큐티님이 내가 믿고 있는 포큐티님이 저렇게 추천을 해주면
굳이 내가 막 인터넷 찾아 헤매면서 알아보지 않아도 그렇게 살 수 있으니까 그런 불확실성을 해소해줄 수 있다는 측면에서 보면
그런 3자, 구매에 필요한 이 3자들의 이해가 모두 맞아떨어지기 때문에 공동구매가 잘 이루어지는 것 같아요.
앞으로도 공동구매는 그래서 크지 않아요.
사실 이 부분은 이미 많이 흘러오고 나서 결과론적인 접근인데
공동구매의 가장 큰 핵심은 일단 싸야 돼요.
모였으니까.
그래서 싸게 될 거라는 걸 전제로 깔고 얘기를 해야 돼요.
왜냐하면 이게 예전에 블로그 맘카페에서 시작된 시스템이거든요.
그래서 어? 모여봐.
우리 200명 모였어.
내가 모였어.
사장님한테 얘기할게.
네.
그러면 이거 85,000원인데 69 해주세요. 사장님.
이렇게 해가지고 만들어지는 게 공동구매예요. 원래가.
이것도 되게 뒤에 나올 결론 같은 얘기인데 셀러는 상품이 만들어요.
셀러는 상품이 만든다고요?
네. 상품이 좋은 상품이 와줘야 돼요. 나한테.
아까 신상품 할 때 좀 좋다고 하잖아요.
신상품의 인입 경로를 인플루언서 시장으로 많이 잡아요. 셀러 시장으로.
이유는 마케팅비를 쌩으로 타겟 광고비 키워야 돼요.
마케팅비를 쌩으로 타겟 광고비 키워드 광고비 블로그 뭐 이렇게 할 바에는
효율이 안 나오죠.
그냥 공구하면
퍼센테이지로 주면 되니까.
그럼요. 수수료도 벌고 마진도 남고 가장 중요한 건 매출도 일으키면서 노출도 되니까.
그렇죠.
이 방법을 택하세요. 많이들 시작을 할 때.
그래서 이제는 옛날에는 홈쇼핑에서 팔다가 좀 안 되면 인플루언서 시장 왔는데.
남으면. 지금은 공동구매 시장에서 충분히 검증하고 가격대까지 맞춰보고 어느 정도 매출 올라오면
일단 홈쇼핑이나 백화점 가요.
그럼 공구가 자체가 되게 궁금해지는데.
이게 인플루언서들이 직접 제조한 제품이 아니더라도 맨날 최저가라고 말을 하잖아요.
근데 이게 실제로 최저가가 맞을까요?
무조건.
그 어디를 다 가도.
그 어디를 봐도.
사실 홈쇼핑은 심의가 있잖아요. 최저가가 맞는지를 검사를 받는데
사실 공구는 그런 시스템은 없는데 고객들한테 댓글로 피드백을 받는다는 그런 뜻일까요?
바로 욕부터 받죠.
다 아는구나 보니까.
검색해서 나오잖아요.
저 같은 경우는 진짜 리스키한 채널인 게 라이브 중간에 최저가가 뛰어요. 누가.
그럼 매출 뚝 멈춰요.
안 사요. 아무도.
그때부터. 나 못 믿겠다. 이러면서.
산 거 취소하고.
그런 경우가 있구나.
1년에 한 번씩 있죠.
그래서 남의 걸 안 해요. 제가 잘.
저는 근데 그게 궁금했어요. 제가 얼마 전에 또 청소기를 하나 샀는데.
저는 그냥 쿠팡에서 샀거든요. 리뷰를 보고.
근데 사고 나서 한 한 달 정도 뒤에 38% 할인해서 또 파는 거죠.
그러니까 쿠팡이 너무 널뛰기가 심해요.
나 타이밍 못 잡겠어.
이거는 그래서 쿠팡의 고가 금액을 사실 때는 조금 신중하셔야 됩니다.
쿠팡은 자동으로 이렇게 시스템이 최저가가 노출이 되면 그거보다 무조건 1, 2천 원 싸게 설정이 되게끔 자동으로 바뀌어요. 가격이.
업체랑 상의하지 않아요.
넣어놓고 툭 떨어뜨려 버려요.
그럼 우리도 주말 동안 그런 일이 벌어지면 당해요.
저희는 저희 전 상품 저희가 한 60여 개 상품을 자사에서 운영하는데 우리 브랜드로.
싹 다 쿠팡에서는 애지가 나면 다 빼요.
그래서 고가의 가전을 사실 때는 쿠팡에서 함부로 사시는 거는 좀 비추합니다.
너 너무 함부로 산다 봐.
쿠팡은 최저가는 아니에요.
공구가 쌉니다.
그럼 이 인플루언서들 마진이 어느 정도인지 이거를 저희가 좀 알 수 있을까요?
통상적으로 25%에서 왔다 갔다 해요.
카테고리에 따라 좀 업다운이 좀 있죠?
네. 뷰티 같은 케이스도 거의 한 50 받고 가는 거고요.
뷰티가 마진율이 제일 큰 거구나.
그렇죠.
전자 제품은 어떤가요?
20에서 왔다 갔다 해요.
전자 제품은 아무래도 마진이 좀 박하니까.
재웅 님이 보셨을 때 이 정도의 마진 구조는 어떻게 좀 판단이 되시나요?
충분히 그럴 수 있죠. 왜냐하면 전자 제품 말씀하신 것처럼 마진이 보통 전자 제품이면 일반적으로 원가율이 한 60%?
약간 여기서 왔다 갔다 하니까 마케팅으로 쓸 수 있는 여유 자금이 한 뭐 맥시멈 30% 이 정도이니까 수익 셰어를 할 때도 20%이면 굉장히 많이 하고 있는 거 같고요.
뷰티는 보통 보면은 저도 뷰티 업체들 보면 보통 원가율이 한 15%, 20% 정도 해요. 많으면.
많으면.
더 낮을 수도 있어요. 10%.
10% 언더도 있어요. 그러니까 여기서 50%를 내가 마케팅비를 써도 무조건 남아요.
아무 상관이 없네요.
그러니까 수익 셰어 해도 되죠. 팔아만 주면.
그래서 우리도 뭐 공동 구매를 해서 만약에 최저가다. 내가 원래 살려고 했던 제품이다. 혹은 너무 믿을만하다. 그러면 사실은 공동 구매를 사는 게 소비 입자 입장에서는 이득인 건 맞죠.
셀러분들도 뭐 특별하게 본인의 이슈가 있지 않은 이상은.
그렇죠.
계속 꾸준히 이 사업을 영위해 나갈 수 있겠네요.
그런 편이에요.
이런 공동 구매 시장에서 남녀의 셀러의 비율이 어느 정도나 되나요?
압도적으로 여자인데 기본적으로.
공감.
공감을 못하는 사람들은 무조건 망해요. 남자하고 여자건 가네. 공감을 잘하는 남자들은 또 잘 돼요. 레시피 베이스로 하시는 분들이랑 청소 베이스로 하시는 분들 남자가 많아요.
나 청소 잘하는데.
전향.
나 너무 좋아하는데요.
무너지지 않는 카테고리가 청소하고.
네.
그리고 레시피 쪽이에요.
둘 다 좋아하던데.
네. 맞습니다.
가능성 있어요.
따로 참으면 돼요?
청셀러로.
뭐야.
장청소.
진짜 잘하네.
죄송합니다.
장청소.
그러면 이렇게 떡잎 단계의 인플루언서 셀러분들 그리고 메가 인플루언서 셀러분들 지금 한 어느 정도 벌고 있는지 저희가 알 수 있을까요?
엄청 예민한 질문.
1세대 메가 셀러는 제외할게요.
HOT나 SS가 얼마나 벌었어.
동방신기 얼마 벌었어.
이런 거예요.
이미 다 들었어요.
우리.
많이 버신다는 거.
이미 다 갔고 다 지나갔고.
2세대도 되게 유명하신 분들이 많아요.
사실 2세대 인플루언서들은 연예인 하시다가 관두신 분들이 많아요.
그런데 이제 3세대들이 저 직전에 있는 분들과 저 정도가 3, 4세대.
세대 구분 별로 의미는 없지만 평균적으로 한 2, 3년씩 버텨내서 꾸준하게 하시는 분들은 한 달에 뭐 제가 그냥 지급해주는 셀러가.
저희 한 10몇 명 중에 한 3명은 억대로 줘요.
달에.
그러니까 수수료만 그 정도 나온다는 거잖아요.
왜 한숨 쉬세요.
공동구매 하시면 되잖아요.
팔아야 돼요.
그중에 대여섯 명은 또 5천 전후반이에요.
사실 인생은 바뀌어요.
그렇죠.
완전히 달라지죠.
그런데 여기 진짜 함부로 뛰어드시면 안 되는 게 저는 셀러를 천재의 영향으로 봐요.
연예인보다 저는 더 심하다고 생각해요.
가수나 연기는 실력으로 가능하잖아요.
그런데 저는 정말 셀링은 인상과 아우라로 하는 거라고 생각해요.
진짜 함부로 뛰어드시면 안 됩니다.
이걸로 인생 피겠다고.
맞아요.
다들 이게 일이 별거 없을 것 같고 되게 소위 말하는 소일거리처럼 적당히 시간만 투자하면 될 것 같지만 사실 이분들이 7일 중에 6.6일 정도를 다 여기에다 쏟아붓고요.
올인을 해야.
맞아요.
그나마 5천만 원까지 갈 확률이 있다.
맞습니다.
그러니까.
시간이 나면 다 찍고 옆에서 지긋지긋하다 그만해라 할 정도로 다 찍고 영상 찍고 이것도 찍어야 돼 들어봐.
이거를 거의 한 1년 내내 하세요.
카메라랑 진짜 친해야겠다.
어르신들이 보면 막 이래요.
결과적으로 공동구매 시장에서 가장 돈이 되는 분야는 지금 어떤 걸까요?
무조건 리빙이에요.
생활 쪽 주방 쪽이 대폭 확장이 됐어요.
상상도 못할 만큼 커졌어요.
그런데 저도 체감적으로 느끼기에 몇 년 안에 좋은 브랜드가 굉장히 많이 늘어난 것 같기도 해요.
그렇죠.
그 시장에서 갑자기 커졌어요.
대표적인 예가 미닉스가 그렇고 롬애나도 그렇고 AMT 같은 브랜드도 사실 한국산이거든요.
그래요?
다 한국산이고 심지어 그나마도 지금 수급이 안 돼가지고 중국에서 부품 수급이 안 돼서 베트남으로 다 돌렸어요.
AMT이고 그다음에 저희가 파는 알텐바도 다 한국산이고요.
잘 되는 카테고리라면 당연히 패션이나 뷰티가 나올 줄 알았는데 너무 의외예요.
저는 근데 리빙일 줄 알았어요.
그래요?
셀러 입장, 한 명의 입장에서는
산업 얘기니까
카테고리를 봤을 때는 그쪽이 훨씬 전방위적으로 퍼지고 있어요.
뷰티는 사실은 K-뷰티, 미국 진출, 올리브영이 커지는 거고 인플루언서 마켓이 커지는 거는 리빙이군요, 실제로는.
그런데 어찌 됐건 공동구매가 최저가다, 무조건 좋다라고 말씀하셨잖아요.
네.
무조건 좋다라고 말씀을 하셨는데 그럼에도 불구하고 소비자 입장에서 좀 체크해봐야 될 만한 리스트가 좀 있을까요?
일단은 AS, CS.
그거를 누가 어떻게 보장을 해주는가 꼭 물어보셔야 되는데 공부 한 티, 안 한 티가 확 나거든요, 사실.
인스타그램은 잘 되는 셀러들을 보면 공부 열었어요 해놓고 일주일 내내 사용법, 관리법, AS법, Q&A 계속 관리해줘요.
음.
진짜 노력의 영역이네요.
이거를 안 해주는 사람한테 가서 사면 자기 스트레스 엄청 많이 받아요.
진짜 아무나 하는 거 아니네요, 진짜.
듣고 보니까.
집념이 필요하니까.
이게 지금 집계가 안 되는 산업이라는 게 의아할 정도예요.
이게 혼자 회사 하는 거예요, 사실.
이쯤에서 재용 님한테 숫자 이야기를 들어보면 좋을 것 같습니다.
우리나라 공구시장 규모를 추정할 수 있는 데이터가 혹시 존재할까요?
당연히 없고요.
없고.
그나마 찾아보면, 약간 유추해보면 라방바 데이터밀앱이라고 커머스 데이터 추적하는 곳에서 라이브 커머스 시장 규모를 보여주는데 그나마 공구 시장과 비례하는 시장이 라이브 커머스 시장일 거라고 생각을 해요.
라이브 커머스가 2022년에 약 2조 원짜리 시장이었는데 2025년 기준으로 한 4조 7천억.
그러니까 연에 거의 한 1조씩 거의 성장하는 느낌으로 성장을 하거든요.
라이브 커머스는 근데 100% 인플루언서가 하는 건 아니고 플랫폼, 네이버 같은 플랫폼에서 하는 경우도 있고.
인플루언서가 자체적으로 인스타 같은 데서 하는 경우도 있을 테니까 그 중에 일부만 하더라도 조 단위의 시장 규모는 나올 것 같고요.
그리고 또 공동구부라는 게 라이브도 있지만 비라이브도 존재하기 때문에 비라이브까지 포함하면 적어도 이 정도 비슷한 규모 한 3, 4조 이상은 나오지 않을까라고 유추는 합니다.
그러면 사실 대부분 인스타 중심으로 이런 것들이 활동이 되고 있잖아요.
근데 SNS 플랫폼 광고 효율과도 관련이 좀 있을 것 같은데.
그렇죠.
관련이 좀 있을까요?
SNS 플랫폼 광고 효과라는 게 지금도 계속 좋아지고 있는 추세인데 결국 광고 효과라는 건 두 가지의 결합이거든요.
하나는 도달률, 얼마나 적합한 사람한테 많이 광고가 도달되느냐 플러스 도달되었을 때 전환율, 실제로 구매 전환이 이루어지느냐 두 가지 영역으로 봐야 되는데
애드 인프레션이라고 해서 얼마나 많은 광고가 노출됐는가 사용자에게.
그게 이제 성장률을 분기별로 집계를 하는데.
지금 2023년부터 2025년까지 흐름을 쫙 보면 2023년에 4분기에 애드 인프레션의 증가율이 21%예요.
즉 광고를 원래 10개 보던 사람이 12개를 본다는 거야.
그게 이제 쭉 올라가다가 24년이나 25년에 조금 꺾이거든요.
근데 다시 2025년 3분기와 4분기를 통해서 14%, 18%.
즉 계속해서 이제 우리에게 도달한 광고의 수는 계속 계속 연의 20% 이 두 자릿수로 성장을 하고 있습니다.
그 말인즉슨 우리가 계속.
네.
인스타에 계속 체류하고 있고 체류하면서 자연스럽게 광고에 노출되고 있는 속도가 가속도가 붙고 있다는 뜻이고요.
지금 추세는 어 노출이 너무 많으니까 어떻게 보면 광고가 너무 많아졌잖아요.
근데 노출이 많아지면 광고 효율은 떨어질 수밖에 없잖아요.
그러면 이제 광고자 입장에서는 약간 고민스러운 단계.
양은 많아지는데 효율은 조금 고민스러워.
약간 이런 추세로 요즘 바뀌고 있고.
그래서 어떻게 보면 여기서 중요한 역할을 하는 게 인플루언서.
셀러.
셀러들이 또 열심히 일을 해줘서.
우리가 공부해가지고 열심히 또 공부하고.
공부해가지고 열심히 또 끌어올리면 광고 효율이 다시 좋아질 거잖아요.
그럼 또다시 이제 메타의 주가는 또 올라가고.
그러면 또다시 메타는 또다시 광고를 많이 뿌리는 약간 이제 선순환들이 요즘에 계속 이루어지고 있다.
이거 많이 활용해요.
네.
그 메타 광고를 인스타그램 쪽에서 플레이하시는 셀러분들은 매출이 커지면 커질수록 수익이 많이 나면 많이 날수록 재투자를 합니다.
셀러분들도 하시네요.
광고비에 투자합니다.
노출이 돼야 되니까.
거의 글렀습니다.
어차피 저도 많이 뜨더라고요.
네.
셀러분들 리스트들이.
요즘 그게 좀 열받던데.
막 셀러분들 뭐 할 때 막 해놓고 원하시면 댓글에 뭐 달아주세요.
요즘.
정보.
아 진짜 열받아 죽겠어 보고 있으면.
그렇게 인게이지먼트가 쌓여야 노출이 더 많이 되니까.
그러니까.
이게 말 그대로 노출률을 높이고 알고리즘에 걸리게 하는 그 후킹 방법 중에 하나예요.
너무 근데 화나.
근데 저는 실제로 그래서 받아본 적이 있어요.
댓글 달아.
댓글 달아서 육아와 관련된 거를.
근데 막상 정보 뭐 특별한 거.
별거 없어.
응.
그러면 이렇게 정보 해요.
그러면.
구독중이 아니라서 드릴 수가 없대요.
어.
맞아.
그러니까.
그럼 팔로우도.
맞아.
아니.
그러면 인플루언서 얘기를 나온 김에 관리하는 소속사들 확인해
보면 좋을 텐데 어떤 것들이 좀 있을까요.
인플루언서를 관리하는 소속사 몇 개를 찾아보면 이제 제일 대표적으로
여겨지는 데가 이제 우리 mcn이라고 부르는 기업들 중에 샌드박스 네트워크
가 국내에서는 제일 이제.
분명하죠.
크고요.
여기가 이제 매출액은 최근에 역성장하고 있습니다.
지금 2025년 숫자가 안 나와서 2024년 밖에 안 나왔어요.
.
볼 수 없긴 한데 2023년에는 697억의 매출역이었다가 2024년에 644억으로 좀 감소를 합니다
그나마 요즘 그래도 좀 괜찮다 라고 하는 데가 레페리 여기는 그나마가 아니라 꽤 괜찮죠 그나마가 그쵸 괜찮죠 꽤 괜찮죠 여기가 매출액이
471억으로 전년도에 360억이었던 것에 비해서 매출액도 꽤 많이 성장했고 영업이익도 60억 정도로 거의 한 십 몇 퍼센트 정도의 영업이익이
나오거든요 그러니까 여긴 왜 좋냐 뷰티 뷰티 전문 mcn 이에요 카테고리가 뷰티면 됩니다 여기 프론트맨이 레오제이님이세요
위에 있던 이제 다른 mcn 회사들은 뭐 예를 들어서 뭐 게임 뭐 엔터테인먼트 이런 유튜버들은 아시다시피 수익화가 쉽지는 않잖아요 어렵죠
수익화가 쉽지 않기 때문에 거기서 mc 소속사가 수익쉐어를 할 수 있는 포션도 그렇게 크지는 않은데 이제 뷰티는 아까 원가율 얘기했던 것처럼
얻을게 많다
맞습니다 광고 단가도 달라요 완전히 달라요 아까 뭐 이전 돌아가서 갑자기 궁금한 건데 뷰티가 조금씩 저물고 있다라고 말씀을 하셨는데 저는 이제
셀링에 대한 얘기만 하는 거예요 공동구매와 관련된 실제 크리에이터나 인플루언서가 판매를 하는 행위가 줄어들었다
인거지 사실 이 시장에서는 그 광고잖아요 광고잖아요 다른 영역이구나 맞아요 그래서 기존의 mcn 들은 이제 광고를
수주하고 그것들을 인플루언서랑 몇 대면
수로 나눌 것이냐 그런 이슈가 있는데 이제 mcn 들이 이제 적자를 많이 보는 이유가 이제 막 수백 명의 크리에이터들이 소속사를 들어 있어요
그러면 이제 그 분들이 다 이제 광고를 수주를 할 거잖아요 그럼 아마 소속사가 수주를 해서 하거나 아니면 그 크리에이터 개인한테 직접적으로 하거나 하는 식으로 할 텐데
보통 크리에이터 직접 들어오는 것은 거의 뭐 9대 1 그러니까 소속사 가져갈 수 있는 포션이 크지 않아요 음 결국은 소속사가 광고를 따와서 셰어를 해야 어느정도 만족할 만한 수익 매분이 나오는데 그러기가 쉽지 않으니깐요
나오는데 그러기가 쉽지 않은 이유가 크리에이터들은 소속사가 없어도 원래 유명했던 분들이죠
원래 수십만 수백만의 구독자가 있었는데 그냥 뭐 약간 같이 할까 하는 형태이기 때문에 소속사가 굳이 필요없는 분들이 훨씬 많아요
그래서 다들 재계약을 안 하시는 거죠.
그렇죠. 그리고 내 이름이 훨씬 유명하지 당신 회사 이름이 유명한 건 아니니까
다 어떻게 보면 메가 크리에이터가 되면 떠나는 게 일상이고
그러면 소속사 입장에서는 작은 크리에이터 위주로 구성이 되니까
또다시 어떻게 보면 매출의 성장이 쉽지 않은 그런 구조로 이어지고 있었죠.
여기 레펠이라는 회사가 육성을 엄청 강조하더라고요.
이런 거에 맹점을 모두가 MCN의 기존 업체들에서 봤잖아요.
뷰티는 어느 정도 가능한 게
그러니까 릴스 중심으로 하면 긴 영상이 아니니까
개인의 능력보다 편집 실력이라든지 이런 기술적인 부분들이 많이 있으니까
그런 부분을 강조해서 계속 우리가 등용을 하고 팔로워를 올리고 있다는 식으로
자료 같은 걸 내고 있는 것 같더라고요.
그런데 어느 정도 설득력이 있어 보였어요.
그래서 저는 이 시장이 MCN이라고 하는 거는
플러스 커머스가 완벽하게 도입이 되려면
절대 광고 비기가 수익...
모델의 대다수를 차지하는 순간
위험하죠.
네, 위험합니다.
절대 성공할 수 없는 구조예요.
그러니까 저희처럼 괜찮은 브랜드가 계속 유입이 되면
예를 들어 한번 상황을 바꿔볼게요.
우리랑 거래하면 아주 유명하고 글로벌리한 브랜드들
그다음에 핫한 상품들은 너희들은 다, 당신들은 다 공급받을 수 있어.
우리만 공급할 수 있는 것들이야.
우리가 한 60, 70개를 총판하고 있어.
딴 인플루언서들, 셀러들 못 받아.
그러면 우리랑 계약하려 할 거예요.
셀러들의 집단을.
보이지 않는 시스템이 아니라 현물이 눈에 보이잖아요.
여기 가면 삼성엘지 거 다 팔 수 있대.
다이슨 다 준대.
샤크닌자 막 준대.
다른 셀러들은 그걸 못 받는 거예요.
그러면 아, 여기랑 계약해야지.
이게 보시는 분들이 어떻게 받아들일지 모르겠지만
저는 이 시장이 언젠가는 올 거라고 봅니다.
충분히 올 수 있어요.
그렇게?
충분히 올 수 있고
그래서 말씀하신 것처럼 크리에이터를 모은 게 아니라.
셀러 에그리게이터가 돼야 돼요.
그래야지 남아요.
그럼 되죠.
재훈 님이 보시기에도 약간 이 흐름이 맞다고 보시는 거죠?
소름끼치게 제가 생각했던 유통시장의 미래를 복수팀이 그리고 있었어요.
뭐죠?
이렇게 하고 계시는구나.
왜냐하면 말 그대로 MCN 사실은 쉽지는 않고
커머스 측면에서도 프론트와 백이 있는데
프론트는 말 그대로 셀러 눈에 보이는 어떤 백화점 유통 채널을 만약에.
이게 프론트라고 한다면.
백엔드는 CS, 물류, 개발 그 모든 영역들이 백엔드라고 한다면
그렇게 백엔드도 하시면서 프론트도 열심히 모아서
어떤 프론트가 오더라도 우리가 백으로 잘 지원해 줄 수 있어.
그런 구조로 가면 그렇게 해서 만약에 우리 셀러 사단이 100명 아니 1000명, 10000명 이렇게 쌓이면
굉장히 무심 못할 파괴력이 생기기 때문에
이제 어떤 제수자와도 협상력이 생기고
모두에게 수익 셰어를 할 수 있는 구조로 가게 되면
큰 회사가 될 수도 있겠다.
하시는 회사가 점점 커질 것 같아요.
그러니까요.
본의 아니게 연간 2배 반씩 계속.
그러니까.
어떻게 2배 반씩?
흐름이 되게 명확한데 이 시장으로 무조건 바뀔 것 같아요.
그런데 이 시장이 지금 노출되지 않고 있다 보니까
집계하는 방식도 나올 것이고
이거를 통제하고 있는 그런 세법도 나올 것이고
또 하나는
심의도 나올 거예요.
아직까지는 없어요.
특히 유튜브는 정말 미친 짓을 하지 않는 이상
애지가 나면 심의가 없어요.
지금 인스타그램 쪽은 과대과장 광고가 아직 만연해요.
이게 분명히 필터링 될 거고 정화될 거고 1급수로 바뀔 거예요.
그때는 홈쇼핑이 1990년대 후반 2000년 초반에 겪었던
누가 TV 보고 사냐, 누가 인스타 보고 사냐 달라질 거 아무것도 없어요.
분명히 바뀝니다.
이미 되게 많이 바뀌었거든요.
재용님은 어떻게 생각하시나요?
딱 이제 양극화가 될 것 같아요.
그러니까 이런 자기가 자기의 브랜드를 소유하고
제조까지 할 수 있는 메가 인플루언서, 메가 셀러들은 돈을
앞으로 3세대, 4세대, 5세대가 돼도 돈을 매우 많이 버실 것 같고
그리고 또 반대로 마이크로 인플루언서도
요즘에는 팔로워 1000명이 1년에 5억을 팔았는 이런 경우도 있거든요.
그런 식으로 마이크로 인플루언서의 시대도
지금도 많이 왔고 앞으로도 올 것 같은데
그런 마이크로 인플루언서를 잘 묶어서
그런 판매와 관련된 도움을 해줄 수 있는
그런 에그레게이터들도 앞으로 좀 더 커질 것 같다는 생각이 들더라고요.
육식맨님도 사실 인플루언서이시기도 한데
인플루언서 시장에서 숫자가 굉장히 커지고 있는 상황에서
혹시 인플루언서분들한테 당부하고 싶은 말이라던가
그런 게 혹시 있을까요?
엄청난 물결이 불 것 같아요.
일단 제가 참석한 유튜브 쇼핑 관련 세미나 행사만
구글코리아에서 오피셜하게 연 거예요.
그거는,
한 번만 6개예요.
그러니까 글로벌 기업들이 이제 완전히 드라이브를 하고 있어요.
커머스가 미래다.
네, 커머스가 미래라고 생각을 하고 있고
유튜브 쇼핑 관련해서 구글 임원분들하고 제가 직접 대화를 나누기도 했어요.
너희 나라가 지금 얼마나 쇼핑 지표가 좋은지 모를 거다라고 하면서
그리고 저는 지금도 유튜브 광고, 흔히 말하는 브랜디드 콘텐츠라고 유튜브에서는 얘기해요.
광고주들이 수주해주시는 광고를 주로 하고 있는데
최근에 만났던 한 커머스 회사 대표님께서는
유튜브의 BDC, 브랜디드 콘텐츠는 없어질 거다라고 단언을 하셨어요.
전부 커머스로 바뀔 것이다.
왜냐하면 한 번 개수로 돈을 주는 거에 맛을 본 광고주는
그냥 이미지 광고로 툭 주는, 목돈을 주는 거로 돌아갈 수 없다라는 거예요.
정액 광고는 안 한다.
근데 이거 맞아.
생각해보니까 패션 쪽도 마찬가지예요.
요즘에는 그냥 링크를 통해서 코드 걸어가지고
그래서 스스로 나누는 식의 광고들이 되게 많이 늘어나고 있어요.
왜냐하면 그게 광고주 입장에서는 리스크가 없거든요.
너무 못 팔아서 한 개밖에 못 팔았어도 내 돈은 안 나가거든요.
한 개 수수료만 주면 되는데 광고는 수천을 주는데 망하면 큰일 나잖아요.
그러니까 미래가 되게 커머스에 있는 것 같아요.
그런 미래가 있으니까 유튜버들이 아마 더 책임감이나 주의감을 갖고
성장해야 되지 않을까 그렇게 생각이 좀 듭니다.
오늘 비주류 경제학에서는 4Q2님과 함께 인플루언서 시장 이야기를 나눠봤는데요.
마무리 질문 드리려고 합니다.
대표님께서 생각하시는 좋은 소비란?
무엇일까요? 좋은 소비? 참 쉽지가 않은데
목적 소비하시는 분들이 제 입장에서는 별로긴 하나
저는 고객이 아니에요.
되게 별론데 쉽지만 구매하시는 분 입장에서는 사실상 현명하신 거고요.
저게 맞아요?
요즘의 트렌드는 제가 추구하는 미하고 딱 정확하게 일치하는데
기호품과 사치품은 취급하지 않는다가 저의 대원직이에요.
실용적이어야 되는 거예요?
일단 기본적으로 실용성과 기능이 갖추어진 상태에서
내 몸에 가장 근접해 있는 카테고리여야만 해요.
가격보다는 몇 년을 얼마나 오래 쓸 수 있는지를 먼저 보시고
그 가격대에서 가장 저렴한 걸 찾아 사시는 걸 추천해요.
그 시장이 현재는 공동구매이고 리뷰는 유튜브 가서 보시고 구매는 저희 쪽에서 하시면 됩니다.
알겠습니다.
육식민 님도 저희 모두 이번 회차가 마지막 회차인데 개그원 호스트로서 마지막으로 함께한 소감 좀 부탁드립니다.
제가 이번 회차로서
머니그라피 10번째 나오더라고요.
이제 저는 한 반쯤은 재용 님에 이어서 토스의 두 번째 아들 정도.
둘째 아들.
둘째 아들 정도의 리프버 한 번 해보고요.
함께할 수 있어서 너무 영광이었고
저로서는 제 인플루언서 삶으로서는 마치 두 번째 챕터를 여는 것 같은 느낌이었어요. 머니그라피 출연이.
그래서 앞으로 머니그라피 출연자로서 먹질하지 않도록 더 클린하게 더욱더 교양 있게 활동하겠습니다.
그렇군요.
네.
석종 님은 어떠세요?
이하 동문인데 사실 여기 나온다는 것 자체가 저한테는 되게 큰 영광이기도 하고
여기 되게 거룩한 자리네 여기.
왕좌입니다 여기가.
근데 뭐 시즌 3에 어찌 됐건 개그원 호스트로 참여했는데 뭐 활약은 많이 못했지만 사실은 애정은 그 누구보다 굉장히 깊다.
그래서 이 방송 계속 영원히 많은 사람들이 재밌게 볼 수 있는 방송이 되었으면 좋겠다는 생각을 하면서.
마무리 멘트 할까요?
네.
네. 소비문화 이면에 경제 이야기 비주류 경제학.
오늘은 포큐트 유봉석 대표님과 함께 인플루언서 시장 이야기를 나눴고요.
저희는 다음 시간에 다른 주제로 찾아뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.
감사합니다.
고맙습니다.